tout a commencé par une conférence de
presse presque banale il y avait
d'ailleurs que des médias locaux quand
l'ambassadeur américain accusait
Prétoria d'avoir envoyé des armes à
Moscou des armes qui ont été chargées
dans un navire sous sanction c'était
autour du 8 10 décembre 2022 le navire
s'appelle Lady air il est il avait
accosté au port militaire de Simon Stone
des accusations d'autant plus fortes que
l'ambassadeur américain a précisé qu'il
jurait sur sa vie que ses accusations
sont vraies la nouvelle est passée sur
les cycles locaux et comme aujourd'hui
c'était la séance de questions-réponses
au chef de l'État au Parlement et bien
le chef de l'opposition lui a posé la
question et Cyril Rama posa avait l'air
un peu surpris il s'est dit préoccuper
et il a promis de mettre en place une
commission d'enquête indépendante du
côté de l'ambassade du crânes en Afrique
du Sud on a demandé immédiatement un
rendez-vous d'urgence avec le ministère
de la Défense voilà l'Afrique du Sud va
donc devoir éclaircir cette affaire mais
aussi éclaircir sa position dans la
guerre entre la Russie et l'Ukraine
Pretoria est officiellement neutre mais
beaucoup lui reproche d'être encore très
proche de Moscou